Em hãy từ để không, mà khoảng được hôm hãy từ đi không.
Mình chào thì các bạn kém cần tìm là dị, tìm lỗi là này để game start at every game.
Cái em phải biết được cái phương trình của quốc, quốc cứ đừng công à sĩ.
Đừng công à sĩ, cái em phải biết được phương trình công à sĩ.
Nó là sĩ mà y e mà em, và các bạn không đánh biết được phương trình công à sĩ.
Tìm đi vào ai có thể cho nó par ra bôn cho nó cũng cho nó cũng cho nó cũng cho nó cũng có đừng thẳng bố đủ đi.
Ừ, nó nó nó nó nó có đủ đi.
Nếu có để bài sĩ, ít thì nó là thường thường cho nó đủ thi.
Nó là, nhìn không, cho cho cho cho thì nó không phải là gách rất đừng thình.
cho cho cho cho thì thì bài sĩ mà thì thì sẽ cho các bạn thêm cái hướng đêm của cái quốc trời.